Gençler merhaba. Hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
Enzimler konusunu tekrar edeceğiz.
Biliyorum enzimler konusunu çoğunuz
bitirdiniz. Daha ileride olanlar
birazcık hızlı gidiyor olabilir ama bu
hafta enzimleri iki video şeklinde.
Önümüzdeki hafta hemen nükleik asitleri
pazartesi günü sizin beğeninize
sunacağım. O zaman ne diyoruz? Hadi
gelin birlikte öğrenelim.
Şimdi enzimler konusu tabii çoğu insana
zor gelir 9. sınıfta. Neden? Çünkü
öncesinde böyle bir konu görmediniz. Çok
normal. Ben size şimdi birazcık
mantığından bahsedeceğim enzimlerin.
Enzimler normalde aslında bir tepkimenin
daha hızlı gerçekleşmesini sağlayan
biyolojik katalizörlerdir. Katalizör
hızlandırıcı demek. Kimyada kimyasal
katalizörler de var. Bazı tepkimelerin
gerçekleşmesini sağlayan. mesela platin
gibi ama bizim vücudumuzda ya da
canlıların vücut sıcaklıklarına
baktığınızda belli bir aralıkta olduğunu
görüyorsunuz. Yani bir kimyasal tepkime
işte 200 derecede, 300 derecede, 1000
stig derecede belki kendiliğinden
gerçekleşebilir ama bir organizmanın,
bir canlı organizmanın bu yüksek
sıcaklığa tahammül edebilme durumu var
mı? Hayır hocam yok. Dolayısıyla bir hem
kaybedecek zamanım yok. 2. Vücut
sıcaklığım ya da canlının sıcaklığı
belli bir dereceye kadar ancak bir
sınıra sahip olabilir. Çünkü biyolojik
malzemeler belli bir sıcaklıktan sonra
bozulur arkadaşlar. O zaman enzimler de
ne yapıyor? Bir canlı hücre içerisinde
bir tepkimenin hem kısa sürede hem de
daha düşük sıcaklıkta gerçekleşmesini
sağlıyor. Gördüğünüz gibi kimyasal
reaksiyonların hızını artıran ve
bunların düşük sıcaklık ve daha az
enerjiyle gerçekleşmesini sağlayan
biyolojik katalizörlerdir. Katalizör
neydi? Hızlandırıcı demekti. Genellikle
protein yapılıdır. Neden genellikle
demiş? Çünkü ribozomal RNA diye bir şey
öğreneceksiniz arkadaşlar. İleride
peptit bağını katalizleyen, bakın peptit
bağını oluşturan ya da katalizleyen kim
bu? RNA yapılı enzim. RNA yapılı enzim.
Ve biz buna ne diyeceğiz biliyor musunuz
arkadaşlar? Ribozim diyeceğiz. Tamam.
Ribozim. O yüzden burada genellikle
bütün enzimler protein yapılı mıdır?
Hayır. Bazıları RNA yapılıdır. Bir
enzimin etki ettiği maddeye substrat
denir ve substrat enzimin aktif
bölgesine bağlanarak bir ürüne
dönüştürülür. O yüzden genel mantıkta
enzim artı substrat çift yönlü ok enzim
substrat kompleksi çift yönlü ok enzim
artı ürün şeklinde substrat ürüne
dönüştürülür. Şimdi bilimsel kaynaklarda
büyük biyoloji kitaplarında indüklenmiş
uyum yani induced feed denilen bir ifade
var arkadaşlar. Bu şu demek. Enzimler
aktif bölgelerini substratlarına göre
değiştirebilirler. Bunu ben eldiven el
ilişkisine benzetiyorum. Mesela bir
plastik eldiven giydiğinizi düşünün.
Sonra da çıkartıp bu eldiveni başka bir
arkadaşınıza verip onun da eldiveni
eline geçirmesini isteyin. Bu plastik
eldiven size de uyacaktır. Onun eline de
uyacaktır. Dolayısıyla burada arkadaşlar
bakın eldivenin kendisi yani enzimin
kendisi substrata göre birtım
değişiklikler geçirebilir. Yani bu aktif
bölge değişebilir. O zaman biz ne
diyoruz? Bakın, substratların bağlandığı
ve reaksiyonların gerçekleştiği bölge
aktif bölgedir. Kendine özgü yapı ve
kimyasal özellikleri sayesinde enzimler
substratlaş girer. Ama hocam neye vurgu
yaptın sen az önce? Üç boyutlu
yapılarını değiştirerek reaksiyonların
daha kolay gerçekleşmesini sağlayabilir.
İndüklenmiş uyumda demek ki aktif
bölgede birtım değişiklikler olabiliyor.
Peki katalizörün hemen burada hızlı bir
tanımı var. hızlandırıcı olarak
aklınızda tutmanızı tavsiye ediyorum.
Şimdi bakın burada bir de anahtar kilit
modeli var. Bu modelden yavaş yavaş
çıkılıyor aslında. Ancak yine de
vazgeçmeyen kaynaklar var. Bazen
diyorlar ki enzimler substratlar ile
ilişkide anahtar kilit modeli
uygularlar. Yani yapıda belirgin bir
değişiklik olmaz. İşte diyor ki benim bu
aktif bölgem üçgense ben bu üçgen
şeklindeki substratla tepkimeye girerim
şeklinde bir yorum yaptırabilir size.
Bakın burada her iki durumu da anlatan
bir görsel ifade var. Bu görsel ifadede
enzimin aktif bölgesi substrata uygun
hale gelmiş. İndüklenmiş uyum. Burada
ise tamamen o substrata uygun bir
şekilde olmalı ve bu sayede substrat
enzimle birleşebilecek duruma gelmeli.
Biz enzimleri temelde yapısal olarak
ikiye ayırıyoruz. Basit ve bileşik
enzim. Basit enzimde şöyle yapıyorum.
Bir protein yapı var. Bu protein yapının
üzerinde bir aktif bölge var ve herhangi
bir yardımcı kısma ihtiyacı yok. İşte bu
basit enzimdir. Ancak bileşik enzim diye
bir şey de var. Bileşik enzimde protein
kısma apoenzim diyoruz. Yine üzerinde
bir aktif bölge var. Ancak bu defa
yardımcı bir grup var arkadaşlar. Bu
yardımcı grubun adı kofaktör. Tamam. Bu
yardımcı grubun adı kofaktör oluyor.
Kofaktör eğer bir mineralse bakın
kofaktörler iyonik formda çinko, demir,
bakır gibi inorganik metal atomları
olabilir. Bunun için herhangi bir
isimlendirme ek bir isimlendirme
yapmıyoruz. Ama bu kofaktör eğer organik
bir maddeye özellikle burada vitaminlere
örnek gösteririz. İşte onların ekstradan
adı koenzim. Yani yardımcı grupların
hepsine kofaktör denir. Eğer bu kofaktör
bir organik madde ise adı koenzim
oluyor. Vitaminler enzimlerin koenzimi
veya koenzimlerin öncülü olan önemli
biyolojik moleküllerdir. Çünkü bir sürü
arkadaşlar onların türevleri var. NAT,
fat gibi maddeler var. İleride metabolik
solunum, fotosentez gibi konularda
bunları da öğreneceksiniz. Şimdi sadece
kulağınız duymuş olsun. O zaman hocam
basit enzimden bahsettik. Bileşik
enzimden bahsettik. Bileşik enzimlerin
protein kısmı apoenzim. Bileşik enzimin
bilimsel adı da holoenzim oluyor.
Bileşik enzim apozim artı kofaktör yani
yardımcı grup beraber holoenzim adını
alır. Burada enzimlerin kofaktör ve
koenzimlerle ilişkisi gösterilmiş
incelenebilir. Aktivasyon enerjisi
nedir? bir tepkimenin aslında
gerçekleşmesi için gerekli olan enerji
ve enzim bu tepkimenin o aktivasyon
enerjisini düşürüyor. Bakın bu grafik
belki size ilk bakışta anlamlı
gelmeyebilir. Siz bir kütleyi şu tepeden
çıkartmak için uğraşıyorsunuz. Burası
enzimsiz bir grafik ama eğer enzimiz
olsaydı bu böyle dümdüz taşınabilirdi.
Yani enzim o tepenin aşağı inmesini
sağlıyor. Düzleşmesini sağlıyor. Bir
biyokimyasal tepkimenin gerçekleşmesi
için gerekli olan aktivasyon enerjisini
düşüren biyolojik katalizörlere enzim
denir. Bu da enzimlerin tekrar genel bir
tanımı olsun. Enzimler genellikle
substratlarına özgüdür ifadesi
kullanılır. Yani siz gidiyorsunuz sükraz
diye bir enzim var. sükrozu parçalamak
için kullanıyor. Gidip de maltozu
parçalamak için kullanamazsınız.
Enzimler genellikle etki ettikleri
substratların isimlerinin sonuna az eki
getirilerek isimlendirilir. Sükrozu
sindiren sükraz, maltozu sindiren
maltaz, laktozu sindiren laktaz,
lipitleri sindiren lipaz şeklinde. Neden
genellikle diyorsun hocam? Çünkü sonu
ojenle biten enzimler var.
Pepsinojen, tripsinojen,
kimotripsinojen. Bunlar proteinlerin
sindirilmesinde görev alır. Bir de hiç
ek almayanlar da var ama genellikle
enzimlerin etki ettikleri substratların
sonuna az eki getirilerek
isimlendirildiğini bilelim. Birazdan o
pepsinojen, tripsinojen muhabbetinde
söyleyeceğim size. Şimdi enzimler hücre
içinde üretilir. Neden hücre içinde
üretilir diye bir vurgu yapıyorum. Çünkü
enzimler sonuçta ya protein ya RNA
yapılı. Dolayısıyla ben bunları
sentezliyorum. Sentez ne? Dehidrasyon.
Dehidrasyonda ne olur? ATP harcanır. ATP
bağımlı bir tepkimenin hücre dışında
gerçekleşmesi beklenmez. Dolayısıyla ben
bir sentez yapıyorsam enzimin nerede
sentezlenmesini beklerim? Hücre içinde.
Ama enzimler hem hücre içinde hem hücre
dışında çalışabilir. Yani sadece hücre
dışında çalışır ya da sadece hücre
içinde çalışır diye bir ifade lütfen
kullanmayın. Çünkü burada da enzimin ne
yaptığı önemli. Eğer enzim ATP bağımlı
bir şey yapıyorsa hücre içinde çalışır.
Ama ATP bağımsız bir şey yapıyorsa
mesela hidroliz hücre dışında da
çalışabilir. İçinde de çalışır, dışında
da çalışır. Mesela biz yemek yediğimiz
zaman ileride sindirim sisteminde
öğreneceksiniz. Tükrük bezlerimiz ağız
boşluğuna, mide mide boşluğuna, pankreas
bağırsak boşluğuna enzim salgılıyor.
Yani boşluklara, hücrenin dışına bizim
yediğimiz besinleri hücrenin dışında
sindiriyoruz ve hücre içerisine
alabilecek boyuta getirdikten sonra
bunları difüzyon, kolaylaşmış difüzyon,
aktif taşıma gibi olaylarla hücrenin
içerisine alıyoruz. Bunu da hücrede
madde alışverişleri sırasında
detaylandıracağız zaten. Bakın
gördüğünüz gibi burada ne demişler?
Enzimler üretildikleri hücrelerin dışına
salgılanabilir ve hücre dışında da
çalışabilir. Dediğim gibi özellikle ATP
bağımlıysa bir şey hücre içerisinde
çalışıyor. Bağımsızsa hücre içinde de
olur, hücre dışında da olur. Hücre
içindeki metabolik reaksiyonlar
genellikle farklı enzimler tarafından
katalizlenen reaksiyonlar dizisi olarak
gerçekleşiyor. Yani aslında arkadaşlar
şöyle oluyor. Zincirleme tepkimelerimiz
var. Öyle her bir tepkime tek başına
olmuyor. Mesela bir solunum gibi. İşte
başka canlılarda fotosentez gibi arka
arkaya tepkimelerle katalizleniyor. Biz
burada baktığımızda mesela şöyle
yapalım. Biz buraya B yapalım. A BCD
şeklinde gidelim. ACD dönüşümünde A'yı
B'ye dönüştüren enzim 1, B'yi C'ye
dönüştüren enzim 2, C'yi D''ye
dönüştüren enzim 3. Burada ne olmuş
biliyor musunuz? Bir enzimin ürünü
diğerinin substratı olabilir cümlesi
olmuş. Bakın, bir enzimin ürünü diğer
enzimin etki ettiği madde yani substratı
olmuş. Bir enzimin ürünü, diğer enzimin
etki ettiği madde. Takım halinde
enzimler demek ki çalışabiliyor. Öyleyse
bunun esas cümlesi ne olmalı? Enzimler
takım halinde çalışabilir. Enzimler
takım halinde çalışabilir. Bazı enzimler
elbette ki tek başına çalışır. Bazı
enzimler tepkimeleri tek yönlü
katalizler. Mesela ileride şu vurguyu
yapacağız. Sindirim enzimleri tek yönlü
çalışır. Bazı enzimler ise çift yönlü
çalışabilir. O zaman şuraya lütfen şunu
yazın. Bazı enzimler, bazı enzimler tek
yönlü
çalışır. Mesela örnek sindirim enzimi.
Elbette metabolizmada çok fazla enzim
var ama biz sindirim enzimini bilelim.
Bizi o ilgilendiriyor. Yani A'yı B'ye
çeviren enzim bir B'yi A'ya çeviremez.
Ama bazı enzimler tersir reaksiyonu
katalizleyebilirler. Bu ne demek? C'yi
D''ye çeviren enzim 2 aynı zamanda D''yi
C'ye çevirebilir şeklinde. Bazı enzimler
tersinir çalışır. Bazı enzimler tersinir
çalışır. Evet, bu da burada kalsın.
Şimdi geldim geri bildirim baskılaması.
Geri bildirim ya da öğretmeniniz
muhtemelen burada şöyle bir ifade de
kullanmıştır. Negatif geri bildirim,
negatif feedback. Bu ne demek hocam?
Şimdi gördüğünüz gibi tabloda A'yı B'ye,
B'yi C'ye, C'yi D''ye çeviriyorsunuz. E
ne olacak şimdi? D''yi sonsuza kadar mı
üreteceğim? Hayır hocam. Madde kaybının,
zaman kaybının önüne geçebilmek için
belli bir değeri geldiği zaman bir madde
şunu söyler: "Benden yeterince var,
artık üretilmesin." Öyleyse birilerinin
de buna cevap vermesi lazım. Siz şimdi
gidip D''yi enzim 1'e bağlarsanız o
zaman A'nın enzim 1'e bağlanacağı yeri
kapatmış olursunuz. Dolayısıyla AB'ye
dönüşemez ve bu da zamanla enzim 2'nin
de enzim 3'ün de durmasına neden olur.
Çünkü ortada B tükenirse, C tükenirse
kimse çalışmaz. İşte biz buna negatif
geri bildirim diyoruz. Ama bunun en
karizmatik cümlesi aslında şudur
arkadaşlar. Son ürün inhibisyonu yani en
son oluşan madde birinci enzimin gider
aktif bölgesine bağlanır. Der ki tamam
yeter çalışma çünkü benden çok var. Ha
hocam ne zamana kadar ortada D
azalmıştır. D''nin azaldığını gören ve
enzime bağlanan o D der ki aa bana
ihtiyaç var. oradan ayrılır. Ayrılınca
da enzimin aktif bölgesi bir anda açığa
çıkar ve enzim gider A'yı bağlayarak
B'ye çevirir ve o zincirleme reaksiyon
tekrar başlamış olur. Böylece bakın amaç
nedir? Amaç ki amaç her zaman soru
olmaya adaydır. Hücrenin kaynakları
verimli bir şekilde kullanılmış olur.
Boşu boşuna madde tüketimi ya da madde
üretimi yapılmamış olunur. Şimdi enzim
aktivitesini etkileyen koşulları ve
enzim substrat ilişkisini ikinci derste
işleyelim. Burada bir mola verelim.